so the topic of this video are what are
called biogeochemical cycles and through
the video I'm eventually going to
discuss the water cycle the oxygen cycle
the carbon cycle the phosphorous cycle
and the nitrogen cycle but you know I
actually have a separate video for the
four I just highlighted water carbon
phosphorus and nitrogen I go a little
slower in those separate videos and into
a little more detail so you also have
the option to watch those videos instead
of the one long video that you see right
here but let's go ahead and get started
so the first biogeochemical cycle i want
to mention is the water cycle also known
as the hydrologic cycle and in the cycle
it's simply the movement of water
through the atmosphere now when you look
at a picture of the globe of the earth
you know about 75% of Earth's surface is
covered with water but there's a problem
with that water most of the water on
Earth is undrinkable it's either too
salty because it's ocean water or it's
frozen like in glaciers and icebergs so
the vast majority of Earth's surface is
covered in water but it's not drinkable
water so we really need to understand
how the water cycle works so we can take
care of the water that we need to
survive so let's look at the stages of
the water cycle you know water rises
into the air in two ways one the most
obvious is evaporation heat from the Sun
causes water vapor to rise into the air
so liquid from the pond liquid water
turns into a vapor and rises into the
air a second way that water rises into
the air is through what's called
transpiration plants will lose water
through their leaves
that's what transpiration so when we
look at transpiration in a little more
detail plants have these tiny openings
called stomata on their leaves here's a
leaf let's zoom on in and when we do we
see it almost looks like an eyeball were
zoomed in here really really high highly
magnified this is an example of a
stomata here it's a tiny pore
microscopic where water vapor can
so this is how water exits during
transpiration so when we look at our
cycle again water is rising through
evaporation and transpiration but what
happens is of course water collects in
the atmosphere and eventually it's going
to condense and form clouds and so when
we continue on with our hydrologic cycle
now that there's water vapor in the
atmosphere condensation occurs because
as water rises into the air it
eventually encounters cooler
temperatures you know you know examples
of condensation on a hot summer day for
instance let's say you take a soda out
of the refrigerator and leave it outside
for five minutes after five minutes you
come back and there's these little water
droplets all over all over the the soda
bottle well did water leak out of the
bottle no moisture in the air water
moisture in the air came in contact with
a cold bottle and it condensed and form
these little droplets so the same thing
happens is when water vapor rises into
the air it cools and condenses and forms
clouds clouds are the effects the
results of condensation and then once
clouds are formed that will lead to some
form of precipitation the falling of
water back to the surface of the earth
and when it comes to precipitation it
might be the most obvious type of such
as precipitation of rain or of course
there's the precipitation called snow
precipitation called sleet it's kind of
like it's not cold enough for snow not
warm enough for rain you get this
mixture of slushy material called sleet
by the way sleet is really slippery to
driver drive on for all you young
drivers so if you ever caught in a sleet
storm pull over get some lunch and wait
the storm out and then there's hail hail
is the fourth type of precipitation
little chunks of ice can fall to the
ground and when you look at this persons
holding hail balls in their hand you can
imagine these things are falling from
very high altitudes naked
cause bodily injury or even property
damage you see here is a broken window
the back window of this automobile has
been broken out because of hail damage
so if you live in areas that constantly
get hail you may want to look into hail
insurance and so once water is on the
ground because of precipitation to one
of two things will happen either it will
run off downhill and runoff is simply
when water runs downhill into a river
into a lake into an ocean or the water
will soak into the soil and that we call
that infiltration and when water soaks
into the soil it begins to collect
underground in the this big pool of
water underground called groundwater and
that's where a lot of the world gets its
drinking supply from drinking water from
is from underground groundwater and so
when we look at this picture here we can
see that there's you know a cutaway of
the earth we can see the groundwater
underneath the surface well what we'll
do is we'll drill wells down into that
groundwater and then we can pump the
water out of the ground and use it for
our everyday needs
so how come how come these underground
supplies of water don't go empty well
that's because of infiltration the
groundwater is recharged or resupplied
or restocked because of infiltration if
water didn't seep back into the ground
water would run out so the purpose of
this final slide on the water cycle is
to show just a summary of the two ways
that water goes up transpiration and
evaporation eventually that leads to
clouds condensing and forming and when
water vapor gets too heavy it condenses
and then it falls as some type of
precipitation when water hits the ground
it will either then run off downhill
where it will soak into the soil as
infiltration either way I hope you see
we have a nice cycle and again this is
simply the hydrologic or the water cycle
so as we now switch to the oxygen cycle
this I don't have a specific video for
the oxygen cycle because this is pretty
quick and pretty basic but the tree
represents photosynthetic autotrophs and
photosynthesis requires the intake of
carbon dioxide again plants have those
stomata which I mentioned it during the
water cycle and when the stomata are
open they can take in carbon dioxide
simply from the environment from the air
and they will use that carbon dioxide to
produce their food in the process of
photosynthesis and as a result of
producing their food through
photosynthesis they will release oxygen
as a waste the oxygen simply exits
through the stomata when they're open
and accumulates in the atmosphere and
then come the heterotrophs represented
by our cow
now again heterotrophs can be not just
animals but let's also let's not also
forget you know fungus and decomposers
and bacteria and so through the process
of cellular respiration
oxygen will be inhaled oxygen will be
inhaled the oxygen that came from
photosynthetic organisms is inhaled and
cellular respiration if you recall is
the process that were ATP adenosine
triphosphate is made and in order to
make ATP oxygen is one of the reactants
and so the the cow is now exhale and
carbon dioxide because carbon dioxide is
a waste product of cellular respiration
and so you can see from the video here
we have a nice a pretty straightforward
overall cycle where the cow gives off
carbon dioxide which is taken in by the
plant the plant gives off oxygen which
is taken in by the cow so when we look
at the carbon cycle I want to look at
the carbon cycle next carbon why do we
need it because carbon is the basis of
organic molecules remember the four
categories of organic molecules you've
got proteins remember proteins are a big
chain of amino acids foods that are high
in proteins would be like fish and eggs
and in steak and meat and let's not
forget another category are
carbohydrates the diagram is a diagram
of glucose you can see carbon in the
diagram of glucose foods that are high
in carbohydrates would be pastas and
fruits a third category of organic
molecules would be lipids here we have a
an animation of the cell membrane the
phospholipid bilayer and so the outer
boundary of every cell in our body needs
carbon and then the fourth category of
organic molecule the nucleic acids the
DNA in the RNA the genetic basis of life
here on earth so that makes carbon
really important let's go ahead and go
on into the stages now so when we focus
on the carbon cycle you know plants and
producers so you see the plant on the
far right is absorbing carbon dioxide so
it can use carbon dioxide as one of the
reactants of photosynthesis and through
photosynthesis this plant and other
types of autotrophs will produce glucose
remember glucose is carbon based so
there's carbon in glucose and then now
that the plant has made carbon the
carbon simply moves up the food chain
the plant has made carbon in the form of
glucose and the glucose simply moves up
the food chain the in the animation
glucose is going to the rabbit because
the rabbits eating the plant glucose is
going to the wolf because the wolf is
eating the rabbit glucose simply moves
up the food chain animals let's not
forget do cellular respiration and as a
result they release carbon dioxide back
into the environment so if you notice in
the animation we already have a little
cycle and we're not entirely done yet
though so before we finish this up I
want to mention of course the role of
the decomposers they're going to obtain
glucose by feeding on the dead so in the
animation glucose from a dead wolf from
a dead rabbit from dead plants are going
to the mushrooms which represent
decomposers and decomposers also do
cellular respiration so they to release
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere so
now we have a full cycle involving
autotrophs heterotrophs and decomposers
and so before we move on I want to
mention the human country
you should you know excess amount of
carbon dioxide has been released and
burned I should say excess amount of
carbon dioxide has been released into
the atmosphere from the burning of
fossil fuels like coal oil and natural
gas so in the animation you see a
factory release and all these extra
amounts of carbon dioxide this isn't
leading our carbon cycle to be out of
balance and so you know later on we're
going to go over some of the the details
of climate change and global warming and
but for those you who understand this
topic it's because of carbon dioxide and
other greenhouse gases like methane are
out of balance with the natural carbon
cycle so with our cycle being out of
balance you know we're fearful that this
could alter you know weather patterns
around the world and and and disrupt
some of the cycles the natural weather
cycles that we've seen for thousands of
years so the purpose of this slide is
just to show a summary of the cycle and
I hope you can see a clockwise cycle in
my animation here and so you can see
carbon cycling and moving in a circular
motion throughout the environment let's
go ahead and go into the next cycle okay
so the next cycle I want to mention is
called the phosphorous cycle and you
know there's a problem we need
phosphorous but there's no phosphorus in
the atmosphere and the reason we need
phosphorous is because phosphorous is
needed to make ATP here's a mitochondria
picture and if we look at the molecule
ATP you can see there's pee in it for
phosphorous we also need phosphorous to
make DNA deoxyribonucleic acid if we
look at a nucleotide we can see that
there's a pea in the diagram because
again one of the parts of a nucleotide
is called a phosphate group and when you
combine one nucleotide with several
others you have a molecule called DNA
and another reason why we need
phosphorus is because of lipids here's a
picture of a cell membrane remember that
a cell membrane is made from a
phospholipid bilayer phospho
phospholipid because those phosphorus
it so let's go ahead and get into the
steps of the phosphorus cycle so when we
look at the stages of the phosphorus
cycle we see hey it's raining in my
animation and that's kind of one of the
most important steps this helps release
phosphorus from rocks there is no
phosphorus in the atmosphere but there's
phosphorus in rocks and when rocks are
exposed to rain and and changing
temperatures and the cold and Thein this
helps to release phosphorus from the
rocks and now that there's phosphorous
in the soil it simply is taken up
through the roots of plants and
producers and now that it's in producers
it simply moves up the food chain and
once phosphorus is absorbed absorbed
through the roots of plants phosphor
simply moves up the food chain from the
plants to the snail because snails eat
plants from the snail to the Frog
because frogs eat snails phosphorus is
moving up the food chain and even to the
decomposers decomposers obtain their
phosphorous because they consume dead
plants and dead snails and dead frogs
and so decomposes like mushrooms obtain
phosphorous by feeding on the dead and
then decomposers kind of complete our
cycle because they release phosphorous
in their waste and so once phosphorous
is in is back into the soil plants can
take it in through their roots and so
when before we wrap up the phosphorous
cycle I want to mention the human
contribution here either humans we're
using fertilisers which contain
phosphorus we're adding fertilizers
because that helps our crops grow better
here's a picture of a farmer pulling a
tractor spraying
fertilizers onto his crops it's going to
help the crops grow better so the
problem is that when when phosphorus
fertilizers are used for instance in
this animation we're going to show often
the phosphorus will be added to the
crops or the plants or even to a garden
at home and then the phosphorus simply
runs off with rain here's a
picture of some water running off of a
farm and just taking away the phosphorus
fertilizers that were added to help the
crop and so here is a little animation
of a farmer spraying their crops with a
bunch of phosphorus because again it's
one of the ingredients of fertilizers
and so now that phosphorus has been
added to the crops
the problem is now that phosphorus has
been added to the crops next time it
rains the rain water will simply carry
the phosphorus downhill and eventually
accumulates in this little pond that you
see in my animation
well this often leads to an explosion of
algae this is causes what are called
algal blooms remember phosphorous is a
fertilizer
it helps plant and plant like organisms
grow and so the algae responds to the
extra amounts of phosphorous by growing
causes what are called algal blooms here
is a picture from overhead of an algal
bloom you can see the green layer of
algae in this little watery environment
here and again another picture you can
see how green the water looks so why is
this bad well this leads to a problem
called eautiful and this actually causes
a dead zone so this water which is now
full of algae ironically life begins to
suffocate you would think why is it
suffocating aren't the algae
photosynthetic and putting oxygen into
the water well that's true at first but
over time this causes a growth of
bacteria and over time when the bacteria
die in decay that decaying process
removes a lot of the oxygen from the
water so organisms like fish literally
suffocate and die it causes a dead zone
that's the process called eutrophication
so sadly again because of human
contributions the phosphorous cycle is
out of balance and we hope that we can
be responsible with how we use
fertilizers and so perhaps look for
natural fertilizers instead of
store-bought fertilizers and you know
you could also support organic farming
in farmers markets because these are
foods that are typically grown without
fertilizers and also pesticides moving
on to the next cycle so the final cycle
I want to mention is called the nitrogen
cycle well you know there's a problem
when it comes to our ability to use
night
most of the nitrogen that's in the
atmosphere by the way 78% of our
atmosphere is n2 nitrogen gas the
problem is it's not usable and here's a
reason why the molecule n2 the nitrogen
that's in the atmosphere it's held
together by a very stable triple bond
and because it's held together by a very
stable triple bond our cells really
aren't able to convert it and break it
down so there's a problem we have to get
nitrogen but the nitrogen the air is not
usable so we'll go over where the
nitrogen then comes from well why do we
need nitrogen in the first place well we
mentioned DNA earlier in some of the
other cycles but nitrogen is one of the
building blocks of DNA we look at this
picture of a nucleotide that we saw
earlier and again DNA is made up of four
nitrogen bases atcg adenine thymine
cytosine guanine they all have nitrogen
in them so the fact that DNA is is made
from nitrogen that's pretty good reason
why we need it let's go ahead and get
into the cycle so when we get into the
nitrogen cycle let's look at area one of
this diagram
well there's nitrogen n 2 in the air but
it's not available to most life on earth
but there are some bacteria that can use
it
so there are soil bacteria that will use
the n2 the nitrogen in the air and
through a process called nitrogen
fixation they will convert the n2 into
NH 4 which is called ammonium this
process where they convert n2 and it
into ammonium is called nitrogen
fixation then when we move on into area
2 of the diagram in area 2 of the
diagram there's another type of soil
bacteria they're going to use the
ammonium they're going to take in the
ammonium and through a process called
nitrification they're going to convert
the ammonium into no.3 which is a
molecule called nitrates so there's two
very important bacterial processes that
go on in the early stages of the
nitrogen cycle now let's look at area 3
there's another group of bacteria
they're in area 3 there's a group of
bacteria that do a process called
denitrification
watch the animation they'll take the
no.3 they'll take the nitrates and
through the process called
denitrification they denied Rifai the
no.3 denied fi means take away the
nitrogen so they get rid of the nitrogen
but they keep the oxygen for their
cellular cellular needs so when you look
at the first few stages we already have
a cycle and that's just involved in the
soil bacteria now what makes this
process tricky of course is remembering
the difference between nitrogen fixation
nitrification and denitrification but
they're each soil bacteria processes
they just do a little different
conversion so now let's look at area
four of the diagram an area four we now
have nitrogen going to the producers
no.3 are the nitrates plants can absorb
nitrates through their roots and once
it's in the roots of plants simply moves
up the food chain in area five we have a
little rodent that is feeding on the
plant nitrogen from the plant is going
into the rodents nitrogen simply moves
up the food chain maybe is neat a snake
eats the rodent maybe a hawk eats the
snake nitrogen goes up the food chain
and then we come to area six of the
diagram represented by our decomposers
decomposes obtain nitrogen you can see
in the animation there's nitrogen going
from the rodent nitrogen going from the
plants and they going into the end of
the decomposers because decomposers feed
on dead rodents and dead plants and dead
everythings
but every organism creates waste and
decomposes are no different
decomposers watch this decomposers in
their waste will release ammonium back
into the soil through a process called a
modification and once ammonium nh4+ is
back into the soil follow the diagram
the bacteria in area 2 can use the NH 4
ammonium and convert it into nitrates so
again what's hard about the nitrogen
cycle are all the different processes so
just do some review and I'm around if
you have any questions I want to do
quickly mentioned the role that
lightning plays in the nitrogen cycle
energy from lightning is going to break
apart the n2 and break apart the o2 so
watching my animation here's some n2 and
some oxygen that's in the atmosphere and
when it
I would lightning strikes energy will
break apart those n2 s and those Oh 2 s
into single ends and single O's single
nitrogens and single oxygens when that
happens molecule called nitrogen oxide
will form and so nitrogen oxide you can
see is just form no.2 is nitrogen oxide
it's just formed and nitrogen oxides are
going to react with rainwater because
you know with lightning usually comes
rain and so when it rains those nitrogen
oxides are going to react with rainwater
to form no.3 nitrates and the nitrates
simply fall down to though in the rain
to the ground and once the nitrates are
in the soil they can be absorbed through
the roots of plants like we saw a few
moments ago so I just wanted to quickly
mention the role that lightning plays in
the nitrogen cycle so there you go
there's five biogeochemical cycles you
know if you think I went a little quick
in either the water cycle the carbon
cycle the nitrogen cycle or the
phosphorous cycle I have a specific
video for each of those four you may
want to try watching those because I do
go a little slower and take my time a
little more in those specific videos so
if you're in my class pause the video
perhaps try to answer these questions on
a separate sheet of paper I'd be happy
to check your answers either before
school or after school good luck